and now eight amazing facts about
Baird's tapir the intriguing animal
you're gazing at this very moment number
one you may never have seen this animal
before but it's been here longer than we
humans have its ancestors have been
around for thirty five million years
number two Baird's tapir is the official
national animal of belize the country
between Mexico and Guatemala number
three in Belize it's called the mountain
cow although it's not a cow it's really
related to the horse and the rhinoceros
number four it has 14 toes four on each
front foot and three on each rear foot
number five tapirs have a rubbery highly
flexible nose perfect for eating leaves
fruit and aquatic vegetation which they
do number six the Baird's tapir weighs
up to 700 pounds
number seven their numbers are dwindling
and they now face extinction because
humans are destroying their habitat and
number eight Baird's tapir was named
after a naturalist who mounted an
expedition in mexico in 1843 he brought
back the skeletal remains of this
species to America and this was the
first time it had been studied by
scientists so if you discover a new
species you might get to name it
scientifically after yourself but get
busy tapirs aren't the only species
facing extinction so are an unknown
number of species yet to be discovered